i wouldn't go there chef
[Music]
what happened to bridget baker
the sheriff is here i thought you were
in the big house
got out a few hours ago you want to
negotiate kid you know
exactly who to ask to get what we want
let's go see your daddy my daddy don't
like surprises
i understand
what's wrong it's dr cheese
can you clean this up
[Music]
what in god's name possess him to do
this
bridgette was everything to me the last
time she was seen she was coming here to
dr keats's house so here's what's what
solve the disappearance of bridget baker
or or i start sending out john keats
piece by piece till you got them all
dr keats means a great deal to this town
kyle's inside now what
you sent my only son in there to deal
with them
we don't have time for games
get in there
get my son
kill the rest a bloodbath won't do
anything
you hurt my boy and i'll reign holy
violence down upon you
my family
they built this down
i'm the sheriff of this county don't
forget who put you there
we're doing the lord's work here
you